oui je soutiens la réforme parce qu'il
faut arrêter un petit peu l'hypocrisie
quelque part les organismes paritaires
gèrent des retraites complémentaires
vous savez très bien préfont la retraite
additionnelle de la fonction publique
mais aussi agir Carco et pour ce qui
concerne agir Carco ils n'ont jamais
hésité à augmenter l'âge du point de
bascule qui est à 64 ans sinon avant
vous avez une décote et augmenter les
cotisations pour mettre le régime à
l'équilibre donc ils le font de manière
très responsable pour le coup sur les
régimes complémentaires et c'est
important agirco pour les salariés du
prix c'est deux tiers de la pension donc
c'est très important et puis ils ont une
organisation qui moi me paraît très bien
d'ailleurs parce que il se revoit tous
les 15 ans mais entre période de 15 ans
pour savoir si le régime est financé ils
ont des points de revoyure tous les
quatre ans d'ailleurs
espèce d'hypocrisie là-dessus qu'ils
acceptent pour les régimes
complémentaires il le refusent au régime
général bon passons sans régime par
point aussi que la CGT a refusé enfin
vous voyez un petit peu les
contradictions vous avez vu quand même
même la grève des poubelles est soutenue
dans la mer du 8ème arrondissement qui
dit il faut un régime spécial pour les
éboueurs
du 8e arrondissement je suis pas
persuadé qu'elle est suivi tout à fait
tous les débats et qu'elle soit
parfaitement en phase ni avec Monsieur
Fillon ni avec Madame Pécresse mais ça
c'est elle de voir comme chez les LR en
ce moment il s'appelait
et pour terminer sur ce sujet là au
niveau des hypocrisies moi j'ai pas de
souci à ce qu'on mette en mettre tout
sur la table peut-être aurait-il fallu
et c'est ce qu'on a défendu nos modem
qu'on fasse les choses autrement qu'on
fasse la loi travail d'abord et qu'on
parle des retraites ensuite parce que ça
aurait pu en partie permettre de parler
réellement des pénibilités je vous
signale d'ailleurs que pour ce qui
concerne les pénibilité si on avait été
au bout de la réforme par point c'était
relativement simple parce que vous aviez
un panier de points que vous attribuez
aux professions qui étaient en
pénibilité ça permettait une variabilité
parce que les professions sont pénibles
aujourd'hui qui ne sont peut-être pas
demain et vous pouviez corriger chose
mais vous regretter l'abandon de cette
réforme par les Macron non mais ce que
je regrette surtout c'est que tout est
refusé en bloc quoi que la majorité
présidentielle propose notamment à la
CGT
de la circulation et c'est une forme je
sais pas je suis désolé de vous le dire
Madame mais c'est une forme
d'irresponsabilité à ce niveau-là sur le
fait que la décote sera plus rapide
je suis désolé aujourd'hui les retraites
sont financées par les cotisations
uniquement hauteur de 79% pour le reste
c'est vrai vous avez raison il y a une
partie de désolation qui a été faite par
les différents gouvernements et qui est
assumé par la solidarité nationale et
non madame la fonction publique n'est
pas excédentaire puisqu'il y a 0,9 actif
pour un inactif quand au régime spéciaux
ça plus les régimes spéciaux en recette
je parle pas en dépense en recette le
coût est de 30 milliards par an 30
milliards par an c'est 30 milliards de
dettes si on avait les moyens de les
payer on les PA il y a un moment il faut
que les régimes reviennent à l'équilibre
c'est ce que vous faites par tout
ailleurs préfons retraite additionnelle
de la fonction publique et agir Carco là
vous le refusez au régime général la
popularité est quand même de cette
réforme qui fait que même le boulanger
gêné
cette réforme parce qu'on retarde de 2
ans là je leur retraite c'est un peu
pire je le fais en responsabilité parce
que j'ai pas envie que mes
petits-enfants mais derrière
petits-enfants et une diète à payer qui
sera impayable voilà c'est tout que
dites-vous à ceux qui sont dans la
majorité qui se posent des questions
chez Hélène aussi on se dit non j'ai une
réforme qui parlait Laurent de même
parler de balle des focus tout à l'heure
excusez-moi quand vous avez soutenu
François Fillon à la présidentielle
quand vous avez soutenu Valérie Pécresse
avec un départ d'âge à la retraite à 65
ans quand certains d'ailleurs prenaient
67 ans et que certains de leurs députés
ne veulent pas voter la retraite il y a
un moment moi je veux bien qu'on
préserve sa circonscription mais soit on
est député au regard d'un projet qu'on a
porté pour candidats et on le respecte
quitte à perdre sa séance parce qu'on
imagine que c'est l'intérêt général de
tout le monde et on va jusqu'au bout
soit sinon si c'est pour sa propre
personne ce n'est plus un mandat c'est
une fonction est-ce que c'est une
profession et moi je ne fais pas
professionnelle si vous permettez sur
les régimes spéciaux je suis désolé de
le dire comme je le pense mais en
général j'ai mon front parler on
applique la clause du grand-père alors
ça on a entendu ça tout le monde a
entendu ça et puis
du jour au lendemain les régimes
spéciaux leur régime de retraite va
disparaître 43 ans avant que ça
disparaisse on a peut-être le temps de
trouver une solution non peut-être le
temps de trouver une solution et de
ramener les choses à l'équilibre
financier ça vous n'en tenez pas compte
non
recette pour financer notre connaissance
spéciaux par rapport à salarié du privé
qui voit ses règles changent tout de
suite
ça ne doit pas
bouger sans de financer des retraites
aujourd'hui quand on est régime général
avait été mis en place il y avait
beaucoup moins de moyens financiers
aujourd'hui
c'est un choix du gouvernement de mettre
ce qui est vrai
il est honnête au moins il dit c'est
pour éviter qu'il y ait plus de dettes
bon aujourd'hui on a plus de 1200 de
mémoire milliards de dépenses publiques
et sociales dans notre pays on cherche
sur les retraites 10 milliards on peut
pas les trouver ailleurs on peut pas les
trouver dans les gaspillages
fiscale sociale dans le pays on peut les
trouver dans 1000 endroits pourquoi ça
les retraites des français
plutôt que dans la poche
claire c'est pas le problème du paiement
des retraites 10 à 12 milliards je suis
d'accord avec vous on peut les trouver
c'est des recettes à faire en paiement
des retraites que vous voulez travailler
au générations futures
500 milliards d'ici à 2005 Bruno
le président ça aurait été un autre
président qui aurait été élu il aurait
été élu de manière légitime sur le
programme qui portait peu importe les
votes vous pouvez pas dire ça vous êtes
un grand démocrate vous pouvez pas dire
ça pas de mandat mais si le mandat de
son programme
du premier tour mais parlementaire je
sais bien qu'on est la mine comment vous
nous appelez la minorité présidentielle
mais d'autres mais enfin on est quand
même majoritaire au sein du Parlement
même si c'est une majorité relative
plusieurs choses d'abord un
contrairement à Stéphane peut moi je ne
souhaite pas et je ne pense pas que le
49-3 sera utilisé
on l'a dit je l'ai dit sur votre plateau
la semaine dernière nous modem nous
souhaitons que ce texte soit voté par
l'Assemblée nationale quel qu'en soit le
prix parce qu'il faut à un moment ou un
autre qui est une expression
démocratique nous sommes les
représentants du peuple et je souhaite
que ce texte soit voté par l'Assemblée
nationale merci